who's this gentleman what up brennan
what up theo
this is robert coming at you a few
thousand feet underground
this gold mine shout out to my hard hat
hitters
got a king of stinging for you jewelry
gold jewelry talking about necklaces
bracelets watches rings
don't have a gold one i got this rubber
one so i don't get my finger ripped off
but kangaroo sting it gold jewelry
gang gang bling bling bling bling
bling and restless too you forgot
wristlets other type of jewelry
neck uh nose piercings never thought
about piercing that sucker
dude i might hang a spare key off the
front
if i if i did i would hang up probably a
spare key that should always lose my key
i got to get a keychain i'm going to
king jewelry
obviously i wear jewelry really hell
yeah i love it love it
never had any pair you never have you've
had you look like the dude's had both
ears pairs
oh yeah i have but i do have them both
ears pierced yep yep
but only because it's all spring break
yeah
only because it's spring break forever
and part of my part
dude we had this kid named billy and he
was he was an alcoholic he might still
be if he's still alive but
he um and this kid named
not billy can fortune my friend that
died this is a different guy
and he on spring break broke um
he like broke his arm through a window
or something and then
he got arrested and so we had to bail
him out so we sold all of the stuff he
brought to spring break we
sold it out on like the strip and did
you make what i mean what do you have
that people wanted to buy like your swim
trunks and [ __ ] yeah clothes
he had a mask he had a couple of just
not that much um
like water doesn't hit your face
hit your eyes oh like uh like he was
gonna start cleaning gear like
snorkeling yeah smart
but he did it yeah we didn't make enough
we made like 70 dollars and spinning on
beer and he stayed in jail for like a
week
but we had a plan i remember the
beginning of that day we had this big
plan we're gonna sell his stuff we're
gonna get him out of jail
and then by the end of the day uh one of
our girlfriends ended up banging that
guy tone lok because he was there
performing
oh oh gee oh geez what was his
main song he had that deep voice right
yeah yeah
oh then uh uh i just remember from
poetic justice
no but tone luke's also in fern gully
there he is right he's the lizard in
fern gully you said uh he's also
in uhura oh that's a good man yeah yeah
he wasn't
you said one of our girlfriends which
one of your girlfriends
uh one of our girlfriends i don't want
to say her
oh wow yeah yeah yeah
wild thing one thing the wild thing
has had more busted people having sex to
it than anything else in the world
oh more tragic humans have [ __ ]
banged the wild thing
dude you've never seen him rap as a
lizard nicole medina
he was bad man he's the lizard and
friendly you're going to hell
hot rap dude i just love his voice man
yeah
one thing led to another yeah oh dude
check out this lizard dropping [ __ ]
bars
what's fern gully dude it's awesome
avatar stole the
reminds me of the jockets i have going
on right now that's for sure
wow as a kid i used to love this he's
beautiful
praise god look at that fat ass lizard
big boy lizard mm-hmm
it's the story of avatar avatar stole
their idea
based off fern gully really yeah i read
the book i feel like can i wear these
hell yeah you're probably cooler than
them
god damn yeah you look like a wrestler
man
you look like you about to just dive off
the top rope swanton look like you're
about to do a ted talk on rice krispie
[Laughter]
treats
everyone's like what's happened